according to the Bureau of Labor
Statistics there are about 3.6 million
people who are at or below the minimum
wage they're working at or below the
minimum wage and upworthy created a
couple graphs on this and I thought were
pretty interesting so let's take a look
okay so who works at the minimum wage
teenage boys 10% I think that makes
sense you get your first job you're
cutting grass you know doing other
newspapers there's some newspaper boys
that's what I did
adult women this one's crazy at minimum
wage almost half of those people are
women adult women teenage girls 14
percent adult men 27.5% now here's the
fascinating part so 34 percent of these
people who are at minimum wage have some
college or an associate's degree that
seems incredibly high 7 percent have a
bachelor's degree or higher 28% less
than high school so that I think makes
some sense and 31 percent are high
school graduates so there's there's some
interesting numbers here some I think
kind of surprising and some not too
surprising but the education one is the
scary one to me I mean the people that
are going to college and still working
minimum wage this is a scary number
right yeah I mean stay in school you
can't up working minimum wage job it's
not the best encouragement right that's
not that's not helping no the scariest
number which wasn't listed on those
graphs is that I believe it's 56 percent
of minimum wage earners are full-time
workers and more than half of minimum
wage earners provide most of the income
for their households yeah we have to
decide if we're going to live in a
society where a person can work
full-time and still live below the
poverty line but these graphs you show
were very valuable because one of the
most insidious arguments against raising
the minimum wage which a decent society
would do it's the least we could do
after destroying unions which built the
middle class is that they're all kids
doing summer jobs their starter jobs and
that's in the case it's simply not the
case so I assume both you guys are on
board this Seattle idea of the $15
I thought we're going to cupcakes I'm
sorry that's that sure what suggested
you want to pay people in cupcakes going
back to our earlier well yeah but I mean
that's a separate issue the week we're
taping this of course is the week that
la that California just raised their
minimum wage from eight dollars to nine
and Cisco it's 1074 an hour and if you
adjust for productivity and inflation
the minimum wage today should be 21
dollars an hour now Australia raised
theirs to 16 dollars an hour an
unemployment went down right it's gone
up since then because of mining closures
but all the same doomsday predictions
were made and they were all proven false
every time they've ever tried to raise
the minimum wage going back to Henry
Ford instituting the $5 a day wage for
his workers on the line at the fourth
Factory and they've all said this will
crush the economy kill jobs it's never
true because if your employees have more
money they are spending more money in
your community and it drives the economy
the middle class are the job creators
and if we're all gonna be low wage
slaves eventually there will not be high
enough walls for the 1% in their gated
communities yeah you know we did a story
in December about literally at Walmart
because they pay their employees so
poorly they were taking donations at
Walmart for their own employees for
three months - well that's the thing
with Walmart is its price is so nice you
pay for them twice you know because they
get subsidized there are some stores
where up to 80% of Walmart workers are
on snap or some kind of public
assistance so you're paying for those
low prices when you're there buying your
non american-made crap and you're paying
for it again every April when you're
paying your taxes and subsidizing and
the the 16 airs of the Walmart fortune
control as much wealth as the bottoms of
40 million of Americans that's
disgusting and it's not conservative and
it's not sustainable and it's not same
yeah so when we hear all those numbers
what are we supposed to do because it's
not changing this is all getting worse
what do you think we can do actually to
change the trend you're asking for an
actual solution like some kind of a
solution yeah I mean job are a lot of
logic into the argument I feel like is
rare yeah no I mean I think raising the
minimum wage makes absolute sense I mean
you have facts and figures to back that
up with which is you know always made a
movie about it so yeah that's nuts
unfair you came prepared
yeah I mean is there
a question about this that I think we're
all in agreement here yeah why do you
think women make so much less than men
still you know even in the white but
even in the White House this week they
show that the average man that's working
in the White House right now I think
makes eighty-seven thousand dollars per
year and the average woman is making
about seventy seven thousand dollars now
I get it there's people have different
jobs there might be some reason but why
even now is it still women are making
less it's almost like there's like a
disparity between what men making with
makeup and on a broader scale so it's
not just the White House I would say
it's not just the White House yeah I
would say it's a national problem it
might be unfair to the white house you
know women make less because that's what
everyone's agreed to yeah and when
everyone stops agreeing with it it'll
change but you know you want a real
solution get money out of politics I'm
with Secretary Rice on this is the only
way you're gonna start it find a way to
get money out of politics look I'm not a
liberal I'm an Eisenhower Republican
okay and why was the middle class so
strong in the 1950s everything
Republicans hate now strong Union
involvement do yourself a favor look at
some 1956 Eisenhower re-election posters
it's all about Republicans support
unions when people have more buying
power you have a stronger middle class
and the rich do better to infrastructure
spending like the interstate highway
plan and socialism like the GI Bill and
a more progressive taxation rate the
rich have never paid lower taxes and
seventy years than today this is all
fixable man-made policies got us into
this income inequality mess and man-made
policies can get us out of it now so
it's not Jesus that's gonna get us out
look if we had a government based on
Christian values we'd be kind to the
poor kind to the sick kind of prisoners
and not start wars yeah there you go
well pretty much everything we ever do
on this show and everything you're
seeing in the news constantly all is
about money in politics so actually go
check out wolf dash pack.com